MARY RADOMILE: Hi my
name is Mary Radomile,
and welcome to Google
Developers Live.
Today I'm here with
Carol Smith who
is the program manager
for Google Summer of Code,
and we're going to talk a
little bit about the student
application process for
the program this year.
Hi Carol.
CAROL SMITH: Hi Mary.
MARY RADOMILE: So tell us about
the eligibility requirements
for GSOC.
CAROL SMITH: So at
a minimum a student
needs to be at least 18
years old on April 21,
when the program
opens, and they need
to be either enrolled or
accepted into a university.
Which means that they
could be, for example,
have been accepted into a
university for the fall term
but not yet attending,
or they need
to be enrolled in a university.
They also need to be eligible
to work in the country
that they're living in for the
time that the program is on.
MARY RADOMILE: Now, will
they need to get a visa
and organize a place to stay?
Or where does the
program take place?
CAROL SMITH: No.
It actually takes
place all online.
That's one of the
great things about GSOC
is that they get to do all
of their coding from home,
and they can work
with their mentor
and their organization
all online.
And they never have to
travel if they don't want to.
MARY RADOMILE: So
why would a student
want to participate in
Google Summer of Code?
What are the benefits?
CAROL SMITH: Well, lots
of reasons actually.
One reason is that
it's a great experience
to get to know an open
source organization,
and start working with them, and
helping them to sort of do good
in the world.
Another is that it's
a great experience
to be able to put
on your resume,
because you'll have a coding
project that you can actually
point to and say, this
is something that I did,
if you successfully
complete the program.
And also you'll get a
stipend of $5500 US dollars
if you successfully
complete the whole thing.
MARY RADOMILE: And
that can't hurt.
CAROL SMITH: No.
MARY RADOMILE: When do student
applications open this year?
CAROL SMITH: So they
open on March 10,
at 19:00 UTC, which if you're
on the West Coast of the US
is 12:00 noon.
And they close on March
21, again at 19:00 UTC.
MARY RADOMILE: And if
someone misses the deadline
by a day or two is there
any exception there?
CAROL SMITH: No.
Unfortunately not.
Every year we get
a few students who
ask us to extend the
deadline or can they
submit a little bit late.
And unfortunately we just
can't accommodate it.
MARY RADOMILE: What about
any like course prerequisites
or any background information
that the students have to have?
Is there anything there?
CAROL SMITH: No actually.
We don't require
that the students
be majoring in computer
science or have
any kind of coding background.
If there's a student
who's thinking
that they need to brush
up on their coding
skills for their
project, I'd recommend
that they reach out to the
organization they're thinking
about working with
and talk to them,
and see if there's anything
that they could do to brush up
their coding experience
before the applications open.
MARY RADOMILE: Great.
And that kind of leads
into the next question.
Are there any special
things that students
need to know for the
application or should
put on their application?
CAROL SMITH: It's up
to the organization.
And so I would really recommend
that they actually, again,
reach out to the organization
and talk to them.
They should choose
the one that they're
interested in working
with, and then
talk to them about if there's
anything special that they
should include.
Most organizations require
a program plan and some sort
of timeline, but
they'll know more.
MARY RADOMILE: Great.
And last, if a student hasn't
gotten all their questions
answered here today
where can they
go to find more information
about the program?
CAROL SMITH: Well, they can
always go to our general
website, which is
google-melange.com.
And on the website there's
a pretty extensive FAQs
that they can see if their
question is answered there.
If it's not we also have a
general discussion mailing
list, so they can ask their
specific question on there.
And then we're also
available on IRC as well.
MARY RADOMILE: Excellent.
Thank you so much Carol.
CAROL SMITH: Thanks Mary.
MARY RADOMILE: And thanks to
everyone for coming today.
This is Google Developers
Live, and I'm Mary Radomile.
See you soon.